don't make someone a priority in your
life when they don't do the same for
you nothing is permanent don't stress
yourself too much because no matter how
bad the situation is it will
change your value is not determined by
someone else's inability to see your
worth
your enemies will often tell you the
truth because it hurts and your friends
will often lie because it
doesn't live life the way you want to
live it because even people who care for
you can't be with you every step of the
way danger is very
real but fear is a
choice
beneath the pain is a lesson beneath the
sorrow is Hope beneath the struggle is
courage when it seems All Is Lost you
find what you really
need most people are only nice when
things don't
matter not everyone is meant to be in
your future some people are just passing
through to teach you lessons in life
[Music]
you must be big enough to admit your
mistakes smart enough to learn from them
and strong enough to correct
them letting go is very hard but it's
the best thing to
do contentment is not the Fulfillment of
what you want but the realization of how
much you already
have life is about balance be kind but
don't let people abuse you trust but
don't be deceived be
content but never stop improving
yourself you may be the only person left
who believes in
you but it's
enough
life just gets so much better when you
stop taking things
personally no matter how nice or
respectful you are some people will
still talk bad about you behind your
back whatever is causing you worry or
pain right now won't cause you worry or
pain forever things change with time and
it will pass
never take someone's feelings for
granted you never know how much courage
they took to share
them if you aren't confident fake it it
will
come no one can make you feel inferior
without your
consent expect ation always hurts so
expect less or no expectation from
others the people who say you can't and
you won't are usually the ones scared
that you
will don't set yourself on fire to keep
others
warm if you expect the world to be fair
with you be because you are fair you're
fooling
yourself that's like expecting the lion
not to eat you because you didn't eat
him worrying only means you suffer
twice don't be afraid of a shadow it
just means there's a light
nearby just because you hate this
chapter doesn't mean you'll hate the
book if it can be fixed why are you
complaining if it can't be
fixed why are you
[Music]
complaining the trouble is you think you
have
time life can only be understood
backward but it must be lived
forwards
you don't notice your progress in life
because you are always raising the
bar let go or be
dragged you'll ruin your life trying to
make everyone
happy if you have more than three
priorities you have
none knowledge is knowing that a tomato
is a fruit wisdom is not putting it in a
fruit
salad people don't get what they
deserve you aren't always responsible
for the first thought you have but you
are responsible for the second
one never be so kind you forgot to be
clever and and never be so clever you
forgot to be
kind your mind gives up a lot faster
than your
body a calm sea will not make you a
skilled
sailor waiting for change while not
doing anything for it is like waiting
for the train at a bus
stop if you find yourself repeatedly
questioning whether or not something is
right for
you the answer is usually
no at some point you will realize no one
else has a say in your life unless you
let
them when you work for someone else you
have the right only to
labor not to the fruits of your labor
we have two lives and the second begins
when we realize we only have
one the cave you fear to enter holds the
treasure you
seek Nothing in life that is worth
having comes
easy everything can be taken from a man
but one thing the last of the human
freedoms to choose one's attitude in any
given set of
circumstances to choose one's own
way it's possible to commit no mistakes
and still
lose that is not a weakness that is
[Music]
life you're going to make a lot of
people mad doing what's right for
you you can't cross the ocean until you
lose sight of the
shore it's easy to fool someone it's
hard to convince them that they've been
fooled any thought you have about the
future is a
delusion resent m is like taking poison
and waiting for the other person to
die there's a lot of things worth caring
about you can either be a negative or
positive person in life but only one
will get you
somewhere before you speak let your
words pass through three gates is it
true is it
kind is it
necessary be
afraid but do it
anyway it takes a long time to realize
how truly miserable you are and even
longer to realize it doesn't have to be
that
way you will never remember the days and
nights you stay home and do
nothing courage doesn't always
Roar sometimes it is a quiet voice at
the end of the day
saying I will try again
tomorrow that mountain you've been
carrying you were only supposed to
climb people often can confus stress
with
responsibility don't cling to a mistake
just because you spent a lot of time
making
it someone once told me the meaning of
hell on your last day on the earth the
person you became will meet the person
you could have
become it is not a of
time it is a lack of
priority what would you do if you
weren't
afraid there are two paths you can go by
but in the long run there's still time
to change the road you're
on hard work beats Talent when talent
doesn't work
hard
the reason you want to be better than
someone else is the reason why you
aren't Embrace stress as the opposite of
apathy life moves pretty fast if you
don't stop and look around you could
miss
it everything outside of this moment is
just imagine
[Music]
ation if you stopped seeing the world in
terms of what you like and what you
dislike and saw things for what they
truly are in
themselves you would find a great deal
more peace in your
life we are all the bad guy in someone's
Story the only person who's ever going
to remember your hard work is you not
this company not your boss only you it's
not worth killing yourself over a
company that'll replace you in two days
if you're
gone the people who mind don't matter
and the people who matter don't
mind keep breaking your heart
until it
opens remember when you wanted what you
currently
have be the person you needed when you
were
younger when you do things right people
won't be sure you've done anything at
all if you are unhappy you are doing
something
wrong be not afraid of moving slowly be
only afraid of standing
still sometimes a hypocrite is nothing
more than a man in the process of
changing the only time you should look
into someone else's bowl is to make sure
they have
enough given the choice between being
right and being
kind choose
kind someone's opinion of you doesn't
have to become your
reality the things you own end up owning
you speak your mind even if your voice
shakes
experience don't
expect experience life do not carry
expectations on how it should
be one day or day one you
decide you miss 100% of the shots you
don't
take youth is happy because it has the
capacity to see
beauty anyone who keeps the ability to
see beauty never grows
old the past is just a story We Tell
ourselves every person alive hits a
Crossroads in life when you have to let
go of the past and Forge ah head into
something
new the only sad thing would be clinging
to the Past once it's Out Of
[Music]
Reach luck is what happens when
preparation meets
opportunity honesty without kindness is
brutality kindness without honesty is
manipulation they've promised that
dreams can come
true but forgot to mention that
nightmares are dreams
too there are two ways to live your life
one is as though nothing is a
miracle the other is as though
everything is a
miracle if you change the way you look
at things the things you look at
change you train people how to treat you
unconscious ly or
not I've had a lot of worries in my life
most of which never
happened to realize that you are not
your thoughts is when you begin to
awaken
spiritually the world is a tragedy to
those who feel but a comedy to those who
think
you are either part of the problem or
part of the
[Music]
solution never attribute to malice that
which can be adequately explained by
stupidity fairy tales are more than true
not because they tell us that dragons
exist but because they tell us that
dragons can be beaten
never go to the
Past not for happiness not for
justification not for
excuses the world is what it is you are
what you
are things are only impossible until
they are
[Music]
not just because you got away with a bad
decision doesn't
make it a good
decision it is not the critic who counts
not the man who points out how the
strong man stumbles or where the doer of
Deeds could have done them
better the credit belongs to the man who
was actually in the arena whose face is
marred by dust and sweat and
blood it's not your fault things are the
way they
are there are more things likely to
frighten us than to crush us we suffer
more often in imagination than in
reality anger is an acid that can do
more harm to the vessel in which it is
stored than to anything on which it is
poured
fake love is mighty convincing in a
world where real love is mighty
rare whoever fights can lose whoever
doesn't fight has already
lost we live longer when we are too busy
living the point of the argument is not
to defeat each other but to understand
each
other life is 10% what happens to us and
90% how we react to
it pain is weakness leaving your
body choose your pain the pain of
discipline or the pain of
regret
work like there is someone working 24
hours a day to take it away from
you the past is in your head the future
is in your
hands a sword can only be formed once it
goes into the
fire many of life's failures are people
who did not realize how close they were
to success when they gave
up if it doesn't challenge you it
doesn't change
you your hardest times often lead to the
greatest moments of your
life the trouble is you think you have
time
you've survived 100% of your bad
days a man must suffer if he is to
remake himself for he is both the marble
and the
sculptor never forget why you
started if you can't beat fear just do
it scared
doubt kills more dreams than failure
ever
will when you find yourself in a
difficult situation and everything is
going against you never give up because
this is the place and time when
Everything Will
Change it could always be
worse the moment when you feel like
giving up is the moment you need to push
harder stop complaining about the
results you didn't get from the work you
didn't put
in one day you'll thank yourself for
never giving
up
what if I told you that 10 years from
now your life would be exactly the
same I doubt you'd be
happy once we accept our
limits we go beyond
them a failure is not always a
mistake it may simply be the best one
can do Under the circumstance
the real mistake is to stop
trying when a defining moment comes
along you can do one of two
things Define the moment or let the
moment Define
you never give up on a dream just
because of the time it will take to
accomplish it the time will pass
anyway
it's supposed to be hard if it wasn't
hard everybody would be doing
it the hard is what makes it
great if you believe it will work out
you'll see
opportunities if you believe it won't
you will see
obstacles the happiest people don't have
the best of everything they just make
the best of everything they
have you'll die once in your
life make sure it's worth
it you can't really control someone's
loyalty towards you you can do so much
for someone and still not be treated
well
if you have to keep asking yourself if
something is worth it then maybe it's
not don't take criticism from anyone you
would not take advice
from leave when a promise turns into a
sorry be alone sometimes it is important
important for your mind and
well-being education in knowing things
means nothing if you're not willing to
put in effort and use what you
know believe half of what you see and
don't believe anything you
hear strive to be the man you want your
daughter to marry
if you blame it on someone else don't
expect it to get
better when you drink you're borrowing
happiness from
tomorrow don't make decisions when
you're angry don't make promises when
you're
happy we are the average of the people
we spend time with surround yourself
with good people to be a good
person if your problem can be solved
with money it's not a real
problem letting go is very hard but it's
the best thing to
do you don't really know the person
you're with until you move in together
never marry anyone without living with
them
first learn to be content and happy by
yourself if you need a company to be
happy then it will make you
weak if you can't take care of yourself
you can't take care of anyone
else trust is built over the life of a
relationship but can be lost in an
instant if you're not
careful no job is beneath one's
dignity if you say you'll do something
do it your word is one of the most
valuable things you can
cultivate and if your word ever loses
that value it will be hard to get it
back the world owes you nothing it's too
big and has too much going on to care
about
you don't let emotions affect your life
no matter if those emotions are your own
or someone
else's if you like what you do it will
never feel like work
being kind to yourself is the best
medicine don't change yourself just to
make someone happy unless that someone
is
you some will call you stubborn others
will call you strong but regardless of
what they say if you know deep down that
what you're doing is the right and just
thing their opinions shouldn't
matter you can make all the mistakes you
want just don't make the same one
twice potential means you haven't done
anything
yet people have to do a lot of stupid
to figure out what they really
want
don't try to fit in where you're not
wanted friends can still screw you over
without doing so
intentionally sometimes when something
tragic or heartbreaking happens you
never truly get over it or move on you
just learn to live with
it your progress does not need to be
seen or validated by others to be
real there's no quick and easy way to
achieve or attain something valuable and
hard-earned
anyone else who tells you otherwise is
trying to sell you
something the only thing constant in
this world is
[Music]
change
letting go is much easier than you think
holding on is much tougher than you
think making others look bad doesn't
make you look
better do what is right not what is
easy no
excuses because excuses don't solve your
problems
real growth is when you start checking
and correcting yourself instead of
blaming others you take your power back
by being responsible for your
life do not chase people who are walking
out of your
life you can't control what thoughts
enter your mind but you can control what
thoughts you entertain don't give energy
to thoughts that don't make you feel
good kindness will not win you respect
except your own but that's the one that
counts you can't change
others if you love something let it free
if it comes back then it's yours and
meant to be and if not then move
on you can't go back and change the
beginning but you can start where you
are and change the
ending one of your worst enemies will be
your own
ego it will tell you that you're never
wrong that you are invincible that you
have no weaknesses
regularly tell your ego to shut
up you never realize when the most
cherished moments of your life are
happening try to enjoy every
day your life won't go as planned and
trust me it's a good
thing prepare for each moment to be a
learning moment
when nothing can go wrong it
will you will be pulled down out of
jealousy don't get surprised it's
normal a bad phase of your life can
start at any
time most of the time you have to
swallow the pain and learn to grow up by
[Music]
yourself don't make one person the
center of all your
happiness don't make them the reason why
you are happy because once that person
walks away from your life you're left
with
nothing trust
wisely and not
blindly
never expect someone to catch you when
you
fall even if you have caught many from
falling it's easier to get into a thing
than out of
it mostly people will treat you
according to their needs and
greed if someone says something and then
says
I am
joking he or she is always serious about
that said
thing people only want to hear the good
not the bad so if you have
issues it'll be hard to find people to
confide
in once you hurt someone they're not
likely to
forget they will always remember how
much you've hurt them
one negligible action can have
devastating
consequences people want you to
succeed but not more than
themselves no is one of the most
powerful words in
existence don't be a people
pleaser you'll be alone in the most
difficult times of of your
life these times will make you wise
mature and
fearless when you're working for someone
else's
dream you sacrifice your
own no matter what good you do to people
they will only remember your
mistakes to reach somewhere you need to
leave something
behind it's best to leave things at the
right time
otherwise you are left with too many
regrets and
complaints you may not realize this but
the people you love are your biggest
weaknesses what other people think of
you is none of your
business
bad times are actually a boon because
they wake you up to the good things you
never paid attention
to if you are
impatient life will always be
harder patience can do
wonders trust is easy to build but can
be shattered in
seconds
worry doesn't take away tomorrow's
troubles it takes away today's
peace don't be afraid to make a hard
Choice the hard choices are the best you
end up
making the more you spend clinging to
the past the less likely your future
will be any
brighter action is 10 times more
valuable than reading and
planning experience is the best
teacher respect yourself because people
can see if you
don't anyone you love can die any
time cherish
them nothing is ever as easy as it seems
good things do come to those who wait
and suffer it might take time and be a
long and rough
road but it's completely and totally
worth
it whether it's a machine a house or a
relationship maintenance is always
cheaper than
repairing
we cry over people but what about
time time is also never going to come
back time is
everything and one day it will Define
you things that will
count you your health and your
achievements you make the best decisions
when in pain because fear of
experiencing the same pain again is the
strongest
motivator the harder your past was the
more beautiful your future will
be most of the stuff you worry about
never
happens you attract what you are you
want to attract better be become
better just because you miss someone
doesn't mean you need them back in your
life missing is a part of getting
over before you are old attend as many
funerals as you can bear and
listen nobody talks about the departed's
achievements the only thing people will
remember is what kind of person you you
were while you were
achieving have at least one person in
your life who gives you honest
opinions it is good to be generous
benign and
magnanimous but there's a limit or
you'll be taken for
granted holding on to things will always
make you more strong
stressed things won't happen in a
certain way just because you want them
to happen that
way learn from what people do not from
what they tell
you don't react in Anger
immediately wait for it to
subside what's said or done in Anger is
irreversible
don't
overshare privacy is
power don't regret the past cuz at that
moment you did your
best see people for who they are not who
you need them to
be never jump to
conclusions be Discerning and let people
show you their True
Colors never Overlook
contempt when someone views you with
contempt and talks to you like you're
beneath them they will likely do you
harm whether relationally socially or
physically remove that person from your
life never lend money because you might
lend it to friends for a few days but
retrieve it from Fools for
years never share your problems with
friends before finding a solution no
matter how challenging it
is don't show your
weaknesses people will enjoy the
show don't be weak in front of
them
listen to the people who tell you what
you don't want to
hear self-pity is dangerous stay away
from
it just because you are going through
hell right now doesn't mean you will
never smile
again pain is purely
temporary you spend all all your health
initially for wealth and then you spend
all your wealth for one day of good
health holding grudges will never harm
people you hate Only
You time defines you you will not be
defined well by anything other than
time time is the most powerful
force how hard you fight it will do what
it wants
[Music]
to